[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
this week in feminism
[Music]
okay claire i understand manual labor
isn't for everyone but we do have
another option available here that uh i
think you'll find quite satisfactory it
does pay around 94 000 a year however it
requires travel extensively across the
country often across the globe long
hours and there are no weekends however
the bonus structure and the benefits are
quite impressive yeah i just
you know we can well
allow me to perhaps narrow this down do
you find that it's very important to
have two day weekends definitely and
manual labor's right out
now what about the long hours and
traveling if you have weekends off are
you willing to work 16 hour days no no
no hmm now are you willing to go to a
trade school i already have a master's
in gender studies so
right right that would be wasted time
otherwise
well there is a position available that
uh maybe
you'll find satisfactory
secretary [ __ ] you
that was to be expected well i don't
think this is going to work are you
hearing from gloria all right you
patriarchy pieces
yes i suspected you would insufferable
well take care i hope you find what
you're looking for in life my guess is
you'll be fat and lonely for a long time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
hmm
that's a nice aerated sip it's good you
have to mix it with the chair right
now that's exactly right if you're being
an affected wine snob yeah is that what
you do you aerate it yeah yeah i'm fine
with it too because it's usually really
good wine and then stay single for the
rest of your life nope got married so uh
hold on a second i just realized uh dave
was filling in let me adjust this to
human height here um
hey that is a good idea though yeah it's
not a bad idea i'll adjust it to non-cnn
producers oh reference height oh should
we talk about that today cnn just can't
get away from the pedophilia i should
call it child rape yeah they can't get
away from it we'll be talking about that
today chris cuomo and his uh uh one of
his producers with underage sex
trafficking um and i do have a couple of
questions for you
why do you think it is so prevalent
right now why do you think this is
coinciding with maps jeffrey epstein we
see this ever comment below it's the
best thing you can do for the algorithm
we've talked about this in the past why
do you think you see it everywhere and
we're also going to be talking about the
gas prices and the state of the economy
because i don't know if you know uh
former vice president biden complained
that he wasn't getting great coverage oh
and all of it changed and now all
coverage is uh slightly more enamored
than before
oh well yeah yeah
i heard they were tough on them yeah
well don lemon brought out pom-poms so
we'll be talking about all of that but
first gerald a how are you i am well
that was just on lemons friday night
that's a normal yes exactly normal
how are you sir i'm all right doing all
right i am doing the shirt thank you
yeah well i appreciate it it's just
plain white so i don't know what you're
uh well no it looks comfy that's how i
know his compliments don't mean anything
it's just false compliments yeah exactly
when something is a nice looking shirt
you say it looks comfy i think both just
like when you're selling a date a blind
date to a friend you're like well she's
reliable you don't know how to take a
compliment
okay thanks you're dressed like a
prisoner yes you dress like a prisoner
white is the new orange is the new all
right i retract it that's a terrible
shirt sir yeah well what are you doing
just like mike rowe go get yourself yeah
this doesn't work either way porter
black is here hey eye for on one hand
i am offended by your shirt yeah perfect
that's it it's a dog whistle yes filled
aggressed upon a c thank you someone
expressions or something someone gets it
thank you very clever someone gets it
and uh he is here he's the quickest man
on his feet he january 16th will be at
the crest theater in sacramento but a 4
p.m show has been added to the february
12th show at the majestic in dallas
because i will be opening for him wow
doing an all-new set and uh probably
recording dave landau special in dallas
february 12th so tickets go on sale now
dave landau ahoy how are you sir i'm
great pretty good had a good weekend
yeah what'd you do yeah well we had
christmas parties for my uh son
and his friends nice well we watched the
heisman deal
and then uh yeah he had a good show
friday i'm sure that he was thrilled to
watch the heisman show oh no we let them
have fun and do kids things right and
then i joined them for laser tag oh and
i heard all those kids very bad that's
that that's the only way to play well
if there aren't a few parent-to-child
face palms you're doing laser tag wrong
yes i'm uh the billy madison to
dodgeball yes what i am to laser jack
boys come over here and play that tag
well i'm gonna punch you so
a couple of things if this show gets
because we will be talking about child
pedophilia over there at uh right yeah
cnn not talking about stealth today no
uh if this gets removed from youtube if
you are watching you can watch it live
on rumble
it's live monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern of course spotify apple android
we can't broadcast live there but you
can watch it live rumble mug club if we
are not on youtube we will let you know
now the last show is next tuesday and
it's december 18th if you are in dallas
or fort worth
uh or is that december 18th no that's
the 21st sorry yeah but saturday if
you're in dallas or fort worth and you
need some presents or your kids need
some presents santa crowder's going to
be spending a few hours
with kids delivering uh some presents
and letting them sit uh letting them sit
on the old knee there you go uh hey i
feel look just also there are still
things that are entirely innocent this
isn't cnn here right yeah yeah should
they bring their passports yes oh yeah
well i'll accept the qr code yeah yes no
no i meant just from just to make sure
they're not foreign not vaccine oh well
no no no i just want the qr code right
and that's saturday december 18th that's
why yes before we move on to anything
else this is important most pressing uh
jimmy fallon uh i guess you must have
seen how well the cold bear uh vaccine
song did right
oh no and you're able to put us in the
because we're reacting to this i guess
uh unfortunately they wanted to jump in
jimmy fallon with his own song
the i we have to see if they're
sponsored by moderna pfizer what kind of
ads are being run 100 on these shows
that's definitely because this is
looking at the point where they're not
even attempting comedy i believe pfizer
is actually sponsored and again i don't
want to get thrown off but i believe
that they're sponsoring a lot of shows
that makes total that's what i hear
they're not sponsoring this show no no
we just have built bars walther and uh
what else i don't care
yes you do of course i care i'm just
saying i don't care if pfizer could come
in and say you will never have to work
again water anti-gay vitamins yes yes
that's true electroshock therapy yeah
basically i want you eating a built bar
being dipped back like shutter island
and coming back up to watch more of this
show that's the perfect viewer
greg pinier films yes gregory films
the intermittent wiper okay so
fallon decided to jump on in with his
comedic take on the booster version of
the song
it's making a stallion
ariana grande oh great do you have
anyone else
y'all know what time it is
it's time to get those boosters oh god
boosters
[Music]
is that the one who licked the donuts
and said she hated america
probably yeah yeah
is he gonna have sex with a dog
[Music]
none of you are wearing masks
[Music]
that's not gonna work
[Music]
i have that same rug
this christmas
oh okay yeah of course megan why is she
wearing bugles buddy
can i get a real nurse please
or a sexy nurse
but an actual sexy nurse either an
actual nurse or an actual sexy nurse did
you just pour lube on the turkey
oh that'll be good when it kills
everyone
you know what i will say though i am
absolutely thrilled that he didn't
manage to sandwich in his bowie and
mcjagger impression yeah that's true
that is surprising
i laugh at it
you know i don't know sometimes i don't
know i do i do impressions
come on do you watch me
and it's time for a boost
[Laughter]
there's no way he could have broke
during that there's nothing that would
break that's nothing i bet you there's a
bunch of b-roll like it's time for a
booster
here's an egg
then he slams a pint punches a wall and
breaks his hands exactly
he's just like you and me he's it's just
like us
he's always joyous unless you meet him i
hear yeah do another matchbox 20
impression you absolute hack
that's the worst thing that's so bad
that's colbert did it worse so let's be
honest yeah yeah that's something
there's some production value to this
but not not good content i don't
understand oh yeah they pay megan the
stallion to do that because it's not
like an appearance yeah and it's not
like she's proud of you i mean she's not
gonna do for free you know she's vaccine
hesitant is she for sure well come on
yeah she made her demographic well her
and uh the other one
who was a pop star it was out with a
similar
cardi b no nicki minaj nicki minaj yeah
but she's actually more based
yeah now it was like i was gonna get a
booster than my brother's best friend's
sister's cousin in barbados he got big
ass balls yeah his balls swell up he
tried he got the big ball
he's working on those for a year what
are you talking about
that's because he was just not having
sex with you for years yeah
i got blue we put nine masks on the
trees balls were still huge
didn't work trees still got covered i
got tree balls
so i put on the tree mask turns out it
didn't create a good seal
why would and i this is
enough already yeah it's destroying the
world
and we're just slowly letting it this is
now the second year in a row that i oh
just well here's the thing too
we weren't planning on talking about
this with the omicron okay yeah we'll
talk about it tomorrow yeah omnicorp
virus yes yes
don't do it don't do it
because then people are just going to
see clips and they're going to see me
see me say omnicron and i'm like why
does steven not know what he's talking
about it's your fault you do this to me
i'm sorry
so i know you're not the omni omni corp
[ __ ]
the overcrowder i just think if we call
it omnicorp if we get away with it okay
the omni corp virus that's a good call
that's a good thing the omni corp just
like calling uh calling uh uh what's her
name megan the stalin lizzo you know
like i didn't say it about her i don't
know
no idea the other other uh fat uh fat
[ __ ] you know mad she'd be if you pour
his hand sanitizer all over her dinner
yeah
she would eat it well i said she
wouldn't but i don't know she wouldn't
enjoy it as much do it over a uh
popeye's chicken sandwich would be an
improvement
that shut up shut up i don't care so i'm
variant when you think about this too
and all references will be available at
earthquaker.com we'll do we'll do a
whole segment on it tomorrow
is okay they are now saying that it out
competes the delta variant right so
basically it's going to they're
projecting wipe out the delta v it's far
more transmissible
and as far as i know no deaths yet no
reported that no reported deaths and
very very mild symptoms we don't know
hold on a second
could you ask for anything better
something that wipes out the other
variants which had the absolutely just
devastating mortality rate of 0.3
percent and now it's less than that and
people don't even get bad symptoms and
it's guaranteed to be the variant that
you catch sometime in the next i mean
when do you have omicron parties
oh yeah you couldn't write it better be
like okay look i want you if fauci said
i want you to write a list okay of
everything you want in a variant and
frank luntz and his toupee and sneakers
like okay raise your hand if you want it
to be more transmissible raise your hand
and then be like okay more transmissible
it will destroy the delta variant and it
doesn't even hurt like here you go and
god gave it to us right he would be
against that is like the version of aids
that didn't kill you yes like no no no
no no no you should not be doing this if
you spike the punch it'll probably just
kill all the germs right ah i would have
a party and be like drink alcohol it
might take care of it just gargle with
everclear that's all you got to do you
can get some mohawk no i love that you
stop it all right no i i have all that
stuff at home in a second there was a
pandemic i just went and bought a bunch
of everclear yeah mohawk the 180 proof
liquor because i know it could turn into
hand sanitizer i knew if crap went down
i could use it for trading also if i was
a drunk or i had a drunk who had some
valuable stuff that i wanted from him i
could use it
barter system man remember we were i'm
sorry i'm going off theirs but remember
early on they were saying don't try and
make sanitizer it can't be made at home
with home liquor i was like really i
don't believe that this is what they
said earlier on now keep in mind most of
the hand sanitizer that you got in the
shortage came from distilleries what
they meant to say was you can't use
alcohol that's 40
well not all alcohol is 40
i have 12 15-year cask strength bourbon
that's 60 70 percent i think some like
120 20 proof yeah ever clear 180 proof
it's 90 you have to delude it to make it
offensive to make it effective and they
were just lying to people saying don't
try and make it at home how about you be
accurate and say it needs to be 60
alcohol they just told people don't try
and make it at home so that then we can
you know use this reinvestment act to
get distilleries on board to make it for
you to do exactly what you could have
done at home no absolutely but that was
one of the ways that they lost our trust
yeah early on and that and then they
wonder why people don't trust them when
stuff like this happens where a year and
a half later yeah the omicron variant is
out there and it's like oh my gosh
everybody like the uk was thinking about
locking down other countries locked down
and it's like but it's it's doing
nothing like it's got now they have yet
right as of today
we don't have any evidence that says
it's something that we should be super
scared of right right i clean all my
bullet wounds with jack daniels yeah
always have you and kesha that's right
so uh i'm my girl
clean my gash with the bottle of jack is
that what she sings no i don't know
i think she's dead
is kesha dead i don't know what i assume
so uh here here's something else too
right now just in case you weren't uh
worried about the state of affairs in
all capacities
on saturday you guys know about the
space you know about the space launch
there dave yeah i was really excited
about it because it's such a great thing
yes it's unbelievable it's one big step
well it's one small step for uh
whatever kind this is the first
pansexual went into space
but then we found out a pansexual
furry what yeah now i don't know if
they're just if there is such
a backlog of qualified
pansexual furry space travelers yeah
it's a limited field or they just had to
you know check and see who miley cyrus's
twitter followers were and pick from
there but the point is this is some this
why why do we need to send a pansexual
furry to space they probably saw the
last minute of armageddon if you
remember where bruce willis puts on a
panda head yes yes
it's a deleted scene or they wanted that
last scene what was it with uh matthew
mcconaughey what's one where he goes to
space contact i think no no no contact
the recent what's the christmas
interstellar seller he's sitting there
crying because he's looking at a furry
yes
so cameron best is the person we
actually found a video pansexual furry
twitch streamer while you're just
checking all the right boxes uh announce
the trip
in november here is the uh i warn you if
you have kids there's nothing vulgar i
just don't want them to uh normalize
this
if you guys don't mind i'm going to do
this video as myself i do mind more
personal
so you're saying the other thing is not
yourself
they're probably a fair amount of you
who don't you know persona like you're
accepted for who you are
you know just because you're uniquely
you nope you're something else you just
said it you may not feel like you have a
place to shine because
you feel like the world won't accept you
no correct
you see that's a good thing
i can't fix that
by going to space
but i do think there is value in my
adventure if i hope that injects you out
the trap feeling
at least slightly more validation inside
of his helmet look like gasps that you
can feel more confident
knowing that one of your people was in
space
wait people one of your people first of
all you're not unique if you just join a
sex club
like oh if you're not unique you can
also dress up like a cat and have sex
with other people who dress up like cats
yeah you're combing the hair of a
unicorn while talking to a can go to
hell
well
i guarantee you yeah uh well it's just
like if there were any doubts like i
don't think you know another it's sodom
and gomorrah even if the guy would if
sodom and gomorrah never turn
if they didn't turn into a pillar of
salt like is that a guy brushing a skunk
head having sex what and
salt it's like right next to sodom lord
you let them make it lord if they're if
there remain 10 non-furries
he's like oh i saw what you guys are
doing i've made another universe that's
much better yes
i'm already over here
yeah yeah good luck that's a broken
clock
well
uh we've actually obtained exclusive
footage now from uh went up saturday of
this pansexual furry's journey to space
and a lot of people didn't know that
they're allowed to bring passengers
there's a plus one oh okay uh so um
history in the making
[Music]
so
[Music]
well there's no gravity
yeah that's hard there are no
limitations difficult really
i'm impressed i'm glad that's happening
pansexual furry gymnast in space nobody
can hear you orgasm no nobody can hear
you
you're screaming scream scream i'm sorry
who says who you think they look out for
each other's needs
they're deviants here's the thing and
look this the reason people are why
okay hold on let me try and gather my
thumbs up take a breath it needs to be
mocked and laughed at every single step
of the way otherwise 10 years from now
kids will go well yeah there's a furry
in space right yeah just a pansexual
furry at the at wendy's what are you
talking about it's not normal okay it is
not healthy it is not a it's it's a net
burden to society when people are acting
as though this is the same as male or
female look i understand by the way i
understand you want to dress up like a a
sexy nurse or you know what maybe
halloween you dress up in a sexy cat
outfit yeah maybe like that with them
and like you dressed up as a sexy cat
that's kind of nice maybe keep the maybe
keep the catwoman ears on that's a
preference you don't go out and identify
as i i am
he
her likes to have sex with women and
sexy catwoman costumes z that's not a
gender it's just a preference and we act
like every single sexual proclivity that
we have is our identifier it's friction
you just love to hear like
houston we have a problem and it's just
they're ignoring them
you're cracking i can't oh houston oh my
dad's there yeah
yeah the last thing you'd ever want and
i mean this sincerely is to hear an
explosion and then no of course have a
gorilla head floating in a pool
space forever houston i have a problem
uh yeah we know your dad never hugged
you we uh don't need to talk about that
yeah we got it yeah that is a very
rickety ship
aliens that's why we let you take it
yeah no
we don't we don't want that why am i
where are they going why do they have me
sleeping in the escape pod
no i'm sure i made the uranus joke the
last show but where are they going for
real is it just in space
to zero gravity and then back down and
you know what the worst part is they're
one of the few people who will be able
to uh
prove the flat earthers wrong see there
you go
yeah it's like west side story with
morons yeah that is their yuri gregaron
that's their i guess alan shepard of
their time they're going to look back
these are the worst okay all right yeah
i don't get it no yeah i i i i get it
i get it so
if you want to know how i get it follow
me on instagram no no your questions
will be answered now i didn't get to go
to space
but i did take a rocket to afternoon
delight oh oh what dressed as a little
bit of a little bit of a skunk that's
dusty skunk and they're sick they call
me flower
thumper
that was his foot all right then they
shoot my mom so
uh that's how the barbary goes chris
cuomo producer um
is a pedophile so this happened this
weekend uh oh he doesn't even look a bit
like one no
who would have known i love how he has
the rosy after sex glow there oh yeah
like what did he just did he's come out
of a gymboree
he walked out of chuck e cheese yeah his
headset that he's wearing right now he
has gap kids on hold
says you got to stamp my hand for what
he's hanging out i like the pizza
these guys are hungry look positively
normal so chris cuomo is former producer
was arrested for luring a nine-year-old
oh good well girl in this case so baby
steps into sexual training uh
what after arriving at griffin's vermont
home the nine-year-old girl was directed
to engage in and did engage in illegal
sexual activity griffin began working at
cnn in 2013 as a producer for cuomo on
new day
um
you know this actually brings me to
this is obviously terrible and depraved
and these people should be buried
beneath the railroad tracks but yeah
this is still when you understand the
relationship with cuomo and
some curious coincidences
[Music]
all right so uh you wonder like how you
know it seems like now every everywhere
you throw you know a stone or an ar-15
bullet there's a
pedophile
yes
there is yeah
without hitting another one you can't
you can't swing a dead pedo or a
skateboard
nope
it's always gonna clip one
they just look at the resumes at cnn and
they're like why sandra hobbies water
skiing golf oh and hurting miners yeah
you're hired yeah look at this welcome
well you know what you know what i
appreciate
is your openness yep you could have
hidden this but you're brave
this says i'm bold i'm here
i don't think that's what it says yes go
get her and be engaged couldn't be any
more bold if you took a poop right on my
rug
oh you're doing it i'm not asking you
but please do but please don't be shy
i want you to feel open to be yourself
we have no secrets here can my secretary
get you anything maybe whiskey milk it's
a nine-year-old it's a little girl elf
from the santa claus
bringing hot
i hate these people
free reign at a child's morgue anything
anything well you know what we'll settle
that later
we'll call it we'll file those under
options so
2 000 now but they don't invest yet
whatever so uh chris cuomo here's the
thing in 2019 this isn't just uni like
the producer's short that's okay you can
say anyone can make it through screening
i guess you know i mean especially at
the cia but yeah chris cuomo himself
said that we shouldn't be concerned
who jeffrey epstein's friends were in
2019. now when we're talking about
epstein
you got to stick to what is common sense
on these things all right don't get
buried and legally
right don't follow the finger pointing
and please don't get caught up in the
intrigue don't forget friends with this
guy who cares
let's take a look at the facts of what
we know about how it was handled okay
yeah i love it he's like don't get
bothered with there was a sex island
right yeah there's no sensationalism
required don't be bot don't be
distracted by the finger pointing or
shockers and what's going where they're
saying the thing just let's look at the
facts he had a sex island with miners
okay
and some of those powerful people in the
world flew there i think that that
matters no no stephen stephen don't
worry about people going there no don't
look at the list listen that celebrity
importance
but then they found the one picture of
epstein and trump who happened to be at
a party together yeah and they wouldn't
stop showing that picture this isn't
right interesting yeah strange it's like
don't be concerned with who his friends
are except trump who's not his friend
hey wasn't bill didn't know clinton fly
on that plane like what is it like 20 uh
20 i don't know 26 times it wasn't that
much 20 points yeah it was like he's
getting that last punch 27 and you get a
free kid he had the up
up in the air granite credit card yeah
so
here's the thing too he attended a 2010
chris cuomo by the way that's just an
admission of guilt what we just saw yes
exactly yeah it's insane please don't
[ __ ] pick her about ooh raped ooh
don't look into it do not look at the
page four of his black books do not do
not look under the letter c
could be anybody here
i want you to look at fredo as your old
jack right
what a dumbass pissed him off so much he
always signed the guest book as fredo
yeah
just talking to me just a marinara
smudge no there there you go
so uh he attended chris cuomo uh 2010
movie screening that epstein you know
was was also attending the party was two
men two months keep in mind two months i
want to make sure i get this right
reference is available at
lightweight.com no conspiracies here two
months after epstein was released from
prison after serving time for sexually
abusing minors so two months after wow
and his wife was also in one of
epstein's address books so you've got
chris cuomo hanging out with him going
to movie premieres with him two months
after he's been released his wife is in
the address books and he's telling you
live on air let's not worry about who
may or may not have spent thanksgiving
with them it's let's just look at the
facts well i'm looking at the facts and
the facts are pointing right back to you
but i'm sure that's just a curious
coincidence
[Music]
now here's the thing if you actually
don't think that it's a curious
coincidence smash that like button right
now if you're on youtube if you think
that maybe there actually is something
nefarious there right
hmm family child rape just smash that
like button to let your voice be heard
so do you i mean it's an honest question
yeah
yes
no but put these things together he goes
to the absolute cnn he talks to them
about what happened why are you wasting
my time i know yeah you really do huh
yeah the answer's still yes okay what's
the question another thing the movie
wasn't the dark knight premiere in
denver
but he was dressed as the dark knight on
the island he's like i'm not the
pedophile you need the one you deserve
i'm gonna it's like i swear mr crumb i
won't tell anybody swear to me
i'm gonna walk away from this for 60
days because i legally have to yes
exactly i'll be back i'll get out of
that jail i'll be back also i need a a
hundred meter yardstick from every grade
school i just wanna i don't like using
this measure so i want lung one long
stick like wouldn't that long stick be
uh hard to listen i want it on my desk
by friday excuse me make it happen i
have some neighbors to meet and i plan
on giving them a pie they will instantly
throw away yes uh and uh that's probably
because i'm going to do stuff to that
pie because i have no self-control and i
don't have access to the island what
would what do you ask of me i'm not a
monk he gave us a cherry pie with a hole
in it well yes what is your question
what do i think no i i was gonna say
like do you think so i'm waiting for the
other shoe to drop with more information
i have no idea what it is but you made a
pretty compelling case here that we have
no idea i might see something else come
out that's looking upwards and i will
say uh there is more with donald trump
and jeffrey epstein than just that
picture yeah however at one point donald
trump did kick him out of mar-a-lago
yeah now to be honest they try and take
this video go look there's trump and uh
and jeffrey epstein pointing at
cheerleaders it's like well that's not
that's not perverted you can say that
that's maybe objectifying but that's
actually that's natural you would want
you want a man to be sexually attracted
to full-grown cheerleaders so that they
aren't attracted to minors that's the
most normal thing jeffrey epstein ever
did it's why cheerleaders exist almost
it's kind of their purpose for people to
look at them
i always find a woman like what are you
looking at my ass uh yes why because
you're showing it to me
it's your job you're doing the splits on
a pyramid of other girls i was
distracted i'm sorry
why are you looking at my breasts i
wouldn't if you didn't have them on a
platter they look like a butt on your
chest and i was curious
my eyes are up here i know but your tits
are right there yeah they're right there
there and they're out yeah that's a good
thing i don't care about your eyes
it would be like me just having one ball
out of my fly being like are you looking
at my balls yeah you probably yes why
because that's what you're showing me
well i'm also showing you my face yeah
but i'm primarily concerned with the
singular ball out of your fly that's
more
interesting
what color are my eyes i don't know
black if you don't let me stop looking
at your titties
[Laughter]
i deliberately went low on that guys
because colored on my eyes irrelevant i
repeat irrelevant
i don't know blue green shut up
stop talking
are they be quiet yes
are they are they nag nag nag
so
hold on before we move off of this story
i want to go back that the headline was
new to me i didn't realize that so this
this producer paid a mom three thousand
dollars
to fly her nine and thirteen-year-old
daughters yeah so that they could be
properly trained yes so it's not just
the nine-year-old it's a mom yes being
paid yes
it it it made me want to punch the mom
yes i'm sorry i'm not sorry no i'm not
don't be sorry it made me absolutely
fury like parents are selling their kids
yeah that's nothing new i know it's not
it's sad this industry just chews people
up and spits them out it's awful it's
disgusting unbelievable i can't i cannot
believe that there are people like that
in this world and yet i know that they
exist well and that's why they want to
they want to actually say there's rape
culture across the country
no it only exists in the entertainment
and media it's the same thing right
entertainment media industrial complex
washington dc you could add that there
when you talk about the rape the sexual
assault you look at the casting couches
you look at ever the most powerful
people in the industry there is a
disproportionate percentage of people
who are sexual deviants it all it exists
in the entertainment industry and they
want you to believe this is the gas
lighting that no no it's red america
right if you go out there you're going
to hear the banjo from deliverance no no
no
it's every week that we come out with
and these are only the ones who are
caught right yeah exactly
i mean would you even be comfortable
just around someone who you knew had a
history of sexual interaction with
children look look at how at that point
they were still flying on his jet
like
like it was southwest for a long time
they didn't even have the self-awareness
because these people didn't fear they
would be caught that's the issue yeah
yeah that's 100 true the largest human
trafficking event in the united states
every single year is around the super
bowl every single time yep and when it
was in dallas in like 2011 when they had
a snowstorm come through they say that
that actually pretty much cut most of it
out because if we had ice for the first
time in dallas in a long time what those
sex slaves couldn't brave the cold no
apparently not yeah come on you've
prayed no but it was it was a blessing
in disguise it was like thank god
because i had no idea i was talking to
somebody why would why in the super bowl
well so it i don't know it was in
detroit too same thing like yeah it's
always been known i don't know why that
is money and power and nobody tells them
no and that's what happens in hollywood
money power fame nobody tells you no and
so you just keep going that's why i'm
like oh yeah secular humanists yeah
worship yourself do you see what happens
when you worship yourself and nobody
ever tells you that there's something
good or bad or right or wrong do you see
where we end up eventually isn't
watching the super bowl exciting enough
no it's not you're like oh i got tickets
to the super bowl but uh i got something
else by the way i know that you
completely lied the lions haven't been
to the super bowl no but they no no they
played there oh really well they had to
toss you away i went there no no they
played they played uh the steelers
played there so the lions were not there
no no then they left the water right
into their locker room like where are
the bags i assure you if there's a super
bowl the lions will not be there that's
the safe bet i don't know if you saw
yesterday's game not unless they show up
to prom
[Laughter]
no this and this also ties back to the
pansexual furry in space look when you
and i had someone describe this to me
and i want to get to the gas prices a
little bit uh and i want to get to the
economy and the lies from the media more
so about how the media is lying to to
carry the water for uh former vice
president biden
but uh i had someone i asked who was
actually more conservative uh lesbian
and i asked this person i said look can
i just ask you i'm kind of confused
and she said well what do you mean i
said okay so you're a lesbian yes i said
so you don't like men at all she said no
you find them sexually just just like
you would probably with a man right
so sexually repulsive
you know and uh she said yes that's okay
so you like women yes so you like women
like like you like women right okay so i
i am attracted to the the femininity all
the splendor that is woman but you date
women who uh wear plaid shirts and shop
at orvis i don't understand i don't
understand how you like women but you're
banging a lumberjack in other words i
like women i'm and i didn't and she goes
well you know what what happens is this
was a conservative person she said once
you sort of break down those sexual
barriers you realize you're free to love
who you want to love and i said well
then why don't you just love a guy she's
like well that's not happening well then
he
while you're dating a danny mcbride
character yes exactly
yes
you're dating a someone with a hockey
cut from the 1980s
mario is that mario lemire no no that's
uh that's elizabeth could have fooled me
so
weird but bro
once you break down those barriers you
know what that's true once you break
down any kind of norms
once you say it's all the same now
the pedophile the map is what the term
they're trying to use now minor
attracted person well there's an
equivalency between that and pansexual
free does anyone want to actually act so
in one instance they're normalizing
pansexual furry going to space right
yeah but then some people are still
trying to say but this is a bridge too
far with the producer at cnn well why is
it because they're nine should it be at
14 should it be at 12 why is one
beyond the pale and one totally okay
because they dress in a costume and
identify as male female in our bisexual
gay lesbian or straight depending on the
day
there is no longer even a thread of
logic and there's no longer a thread of
natural
rights at this point that man and woman
go together i mean do you understand
these things are all related you can't
just totally break down the the barriers
of normality it by the way remember safe
sex healthy sex well that's out the
window now
what do you think is happening when
you're banging someone through three
layers of felt
i think if they send that pedo into
space though it should just say acme and
be litten by wild
coyote send them into space and just
like with a few pencils just
pop it and watch their head go turn into
mr mackey in space and we'll all have a
good laugh yeah this looks more like a
missile than a rocket ship just get in
yeah get in
enjoy your trip this is bezos right so
this is blue origin this is him trying
to get everybody to
not pay attention i made a penis rocket
yes i'm a billionaire it's like a
phallic symbol it's like oh okay i guess
rockets naturally do yeah but you don't
have to like go with it you didn't have
to put balls on it leaned into this
rocket in flight
pedophiles delight
pedophiles delight
that was good guys yeah no problem thank
you i am ashamed that that is but you
know what it's the news
oh no they also work for the news yes
that's true they also control the
newspaper think about this you would be
more offended at someone like me the
left the liberals the liberal watching
right now you'd be more offended at
someone like me
commentating
on the news then a pedophile running it
we will find no common ground nope okay
in case you missed it former vice
president joseph r biden
ruins everything he touches like charlie
brown that's true everything i touch
turns to ruins so uh
before we move on to how he's been
trying to manipulate the press give me a
quick list of just his low lights some
of his low lights include inflation at a
40-year high 40. southern border the
encounters have doubled in 2021 oops
that's a party good thing not good
encounters botched the afghanistan
withdrawal according to some people
country you know the people that are
still over there fighting for their
lives uh forced vaccination but that's
yeah that's why i see it as a free
vaccination that's that's not i'm just
being fair and balanced yeah well that
is fair and that is balanced that's a
joke just a few of the things yet
according to the media uh this man and
we wonder why the media is i noticed a
shift where they're trying to say ah
biden's not getting fair coverage uh
they believe he's the most persecuted
person behind gandhi uh jesus joan of
arc and pansexual furries it started out
for biden fairly favorable coverage the
first few months of the year uh the last
four months however uh biden looks like
uh the guy from the house with
absolutely donald trump was more lower
than where donald trump is in terms of
it's the media
it's the actual words we're using the
wrong type we are as negative as a
collective media uh on joe biden if not
more so
than we were to donald trump at a time
when he was trying to overthrow
democracy and i think that he wasn't
tremendous indictment of our whole
industry you're still doing it
hold on
did he just say that they're more being
harder on joe biden than they were in
donald trump yeah i guess yeah by not
asking them questions it makes it much
more difficult for the president yeah
it's really brain scrambled from banging
all the nine-year-olds is that is that
what's happening right there yeah i
think so
terrible he said he was
more on biden while he was all
diminishing trump at the same time yes
good thing is we have the tail of the
tape here
all references available link in the
description uh lodwithcrowder.com uh of
course they were all very cordial
towards president remember the question
a lot of people are asking although a
lot of people think they have the answer
is is the president a racist that
dossier alleged that russians had a
so-called p-tape of prostitutes that
trump had paid to urinate on each other
and his bed in a russian hotel suite i
have that honey mr president that's
enough this president i had one of these
i may ask on on the russia investigation
are you concerned that that you may have
i'm not concerned about anything with
you
investigation because it's a hoax that's
enough put down the mic this president
are you worried about indictments coming
down in this investigation you are fake
you don't have the luxury to take a back
seat as this man is
arrogantly marching us towards fascism
that is the president of the united
states that is the most powerful person
in the world and we see him
like an obese turtle on his back
flailing no he's not trying to bang it
realizing his time is over so
he's a big dumb dumb and i hate him you
know he just had obese turtle on its
back on the brain well oh yeah yeah he
watched breaking bad and he's like what
happens if you flip the thing we were to
do an ammo they put them into the the
mri machine you'd come to that tube like
that's nothing but fat turtles on their
backs what are you doing anderson it's
nothing it's just i can't say anything
but the obese turtle he just saw stelter
slip on a wet floor yes
he's just
like the brother of christmas i can't
get up i can't get up i'm too straight
to get up guys help it was it was tapper
pulling at tonya harding to get cuomo's
slot yes
put him on his back so here's what's
funny is uh biden must have agreed that
he wasn't getting good enough treatment
from the media cronies because he sent
out a team allegedly to persuade
newsrooms to give him better coverage oh
really so this comes from oliver darcy
one of the worst people in media by the
way uh
and he wrote the white house not happy
with the news media's coverage of the
supply chain and economy has been
working behind the scenes trying to
reshape coverage
in its favor and it didn't take long
here's what's funny is the good thing is
we have the timeline it did not take
long at all for the most lackey-ish of
the lackeys to fall in line here is don
lemon uh
gushing i should say just more so elated
over the uh dropping
ball gas prices big economic relief for
millions of americans who have been
dealing with soaring energy prices
cost of the pump
finally easing up with the national
average for a gallon of regular falling
to three dollars and 35 cents
it's october just the lowest since one
month
now i can feed my kids government is
forecasting gas will drop to three
dollars
and one cent
by january oh will only drop to double
what it was
this is hilarious by after the holidays
in merry christmas i love how even in
trying to sell it he's like the lowest
since october that's one month that was
december 7th yeah by the way he goes oh
that was not us we did not put a sound
effect on that that was him yeah and he
looked through a window at uh gay black
origin you had somewhere in my memories
oh boy
he does that and looks like you can mess
with a lot of things yeah but you can't
mess with gay blacks on christmas
he thinks something different than we
think oh very gay black christmas direct
hit so here's the chart they're showing
to show you the gas prices yeah right
they're going now here's the chart
zoomed out the exact same chart
i did not see that that's not like a
10-year chart no it's not that's like a
year and a half yeah it's like a year
like it's it's pretty let's do it again
one month look at that one month wow
how and then here's the real chart i
think it's like a three month chart
that's like that's from september of
2020 yeah september because that was
because he had uh his pool boy like
under his table like police academy
it's like bitcoin from the day it was
invented or amazon stuck
literally going up the minute donald
trump loses the election oh yeah it's 20
20. and again this just there can be no
object do you think for a second that
don lemon actually believes that gas is
at a more affordable price right now
that this is more fair of course not
seven does he care or even notice no i
don't even he doesn't drive himself
following words he's like it's down to 3
35 and i'm like 335 really like that's
low gas for you that sucks you
understand and by the way
yeah that's like the big headline three
dollars in one cent i'm like so you're
still getting screwed and you're la
you're loving that yeah i preferred it
when uh donald trump was president it
was closer to one yeah well why not just
say 299 like you know everything doesn't
make it sound like it's less than it is
because he can't lie that badly that's
awesome oh yeah you can't live on it don
lemon has standards yeah that's true
very low gosh how about do a better job
joe biden you want better coverage do a
better job
you know what listen the tomato that's
too much
no too much to ask here's jim cramer
saying that joe biden has created the
strong this guy by the way someone just
needs to someone can we get gallagher to
hit his head with a mallet we should
because this guy's always hit jim cramer
is always hitting stuff with like ch
children's toys i guess that's his
gimmick when he's a soundboard thing but
no but he has a guy he's sitting there
he's like hey you guys got to buy tesla
like
clock
clock
wooden plane that he got at dave and
buster's like how is this what
yeah
he's like one of the really sticky hands
and he's throwing it on the camera lens
by apple oh
okay so apparently this is the show
financial aid mission yeah whoopee
cushion yeah like how does this work
oh self-inflating uh he said this is one
of the strongest economies he's ever
seen to me we have the strongest economy
perhaps i have ever seen said number
this morning that unemployment are it's
the best in years not best in 69. we
have all spotted the endless help wanted
signs the housing apartment shortages
the tremendous demand for goods and
services a marvel to behold
cause they're in the bag about their
jobs i say fantastic and the ability to
even get better ones if they want to
they're spending more than i've ever
seen but they're doing it with cash not
on credit they're doing so
in a rowing 20 style okay shut up shut
up shut up a couple things first off
people if people are doing it with cash
it's because the government gave them
cash by the way you're welcome was still
paying taxes throughout all this yeah
and he just said lowest unemployment
that's just a lie
it's not even i tried to see where he
was getting it from the unemployment is
still higher now than it was
pre-pandemic period and even without
including this though we have a 40 45
years sorry 45-year labor participation
low wow so in other words that
unemployment should be way lower than it
is it's still higher than pre-pandemic
and fewer people are looking for jobs or
entering the workforce than ever before
i feel like i'm also in bizarro world
did you hear what he said
1920s
right at the end there what happened at
the end of the 1920s the worst
depression the world has ever seen it's
the 30s that's a problem
okay yeah i'm just saying why would you
say something like that
wait a minute wait this this actually
led to the world almost dying yeah i'm
cheering it off isn't he the guy that
tells you what stocks to buy yes yeah oh
i hope their windows don't open on that
floor yeah
i don't understand he's the kind of guy
who would try and kill himself in a
garage with a tesla yeah there you go
put his mouth on the exhaust of a
battery
sweetheart run the dyson i gotta get
this moving faster
very a little buzzy it's like when you
get the georgia farming battery it's all
so clean
[Laughter]
i will never why would you buy a stock
from that guy i'll tell you what's going
up you don't know
i don't want to talk to you no more yeah
you know what i don't buy anything gold
things that go up when the market
crashes not necessarily gold is not
necessarily the safest hedge builds
but it's one of the most predictable
bill development
well that's that's only fair yeah i'm
gonna have more catheters than i know
what to do
[Laughter]
i know what stocking stuffers will be
getting this year
my old ones never could get clean or
dishwasher safe
one of them broke and now i can pee
around a corner i'd have to blow the
crud out
had my manhood right angled because of
gerald stalking so uh
this headline from the new republic
might say it all it says is criticizing
joe biden a danger to democracy
nope is it but now there's no difference
between cnn and north korean media just
to be clear uh or canadian broadcasting
cbc or china china yeah venezuela or the
bbc well yeah that's the bbc going gosh
money really sucks in other countries
for as much as people [ __ ] about the
corporate media it's like well at least
you have options right yeah yeah exactly
rt not not anything else though and this
reminds me too a lot of you may not
remember this so this a lot of people
now will be saying always i'm seeing cnn
like joe rogan just said this recently
like i feel like cnn used to be facts
and now no look i remember when this man
andrew breitbart i sat under him under
his tutelage and at this point in time
it was actually from a slate writer to
give them credit but andrew breitbart
really brought it to the forefront under
the obama era there was something called
journal list was the scandal and uh it
was actually this group of journalists
who conspired on how to attack john
mccain's campaign after he chose sarah
palin as vp and they were sort of
sending out talking points people from
the obama campaign you guys can read
about it at loud with credit.com this is
back during the obama campaign so
pre-2009 to be clear um people who were
involved ezra klein you know vox
maddy iglesias jeffrey tubin
apparently he had more time on his hands
uh chris hayes better than so there was
never a point that this media was was
unbiased this is something i want to see
die and you know what comment below did
you actually buy into this lie that
walter cronkite was a journalist did you
actually buy into this slide that brian
williams with a journalist did you
actually buy into the slide that dan
rather was a journalist barbara walters
take your pick take your pick from any
of them at any point it was always
incredibly biased you just didn't have
shows like this shows like ben shapiro
podcast to call them on their crap and
so i i hate it when people say let's
return to the golden era of journalism
it's a lie it never existed
but it's a lot harder for people to
accept i hate to tell you this you were
fooled you were fooled the reason that
the biden administration feels so
comfortable reaching out and demanding
this is because
his the previous administration former
vice president when he was there as he
is now under obama they would reach out
and say hey make sure you give us this
coverage and people would get mad at
think about this for a second they would
get mad at donald trump right there when
he was talking to i believe it was
acosta where he goes it's a hoax you're
fake excuse me okay your fake news
everyone knows your fake news everyone
everyone knows you're fake stop put the
microphone down and people would get mad
at donald trump's reaction but here's
the truth it cannot be about the
reaction it needs to be about
the initial action the lie jim acosta
was talking about the russian collusion
hoax it was a lie but the media would go
lie lie lie look at the reaction whereas
right now they don't even hit biden with
the truth they go hey best unemployment
that's a lie
they lied to hurt donald trump and they
will lie to help joe biden it is that
simple it's what they've always done you
can go back remember when ronald reagan
died
when ronald reagan died there were so
many in media in any entertainment
industry who were shocked to see the
country mourn him yeah i remember just
there was this disconnect where they
were like well you know he was president
so i guess it's sad but uh wasn't and
then they saw all of these americans
this was america's president it just
goes to show you how out of touch the
media was back then
and i think this all really came to a
head for people we really started to see
this happen with obama we started to see
the media just praise and praise and
praise and praise and i think that's one
of the things that motivated donald
trump to say look you guys have to see
this if you don't see this you won't
have a country right this was one of his
primary messages like you're being lied
to on a daily basis they're doing it
because they don't like you they don't
like what you stand for and they don't
want the america that you grew up in
these people would feel more at ease in
a spaceship with a pansexual furry
than they would
with uh than they would with uh with you
in church on some which by the way i
think actually we have more uh footage
right now
pansexuals in space
[Music]
[Music]
oh well they were just saving money on a
set at that point we shouldn't be paying
for that no at least somebody's getting
off oh they own the rights i'm just glad
that they're enjoying their trip yes
it's going to be on prime later so yeah
well i hope they enjoy their trip it's
going to be on one of the plus channels
yes everything now it's going to be an
lgbt month
lgbtq plus plus yes pride month
pride months learn about black history
i'm like i need to watch 12 years of
slave or roots again
i watched 12 years a slave in the
theater and i was like boy am i
uncomfortable
everybody did you ever try and watch the
moonlight
i tried to watch it it was sent to me
yeah for like the screener screeners
yeah yeah it's pretty rough
yeah that girl's a lupe whatever she's
she's quite the dish though i was
watching glory on a plane love denzel
that was fun
wait wait wait wait you remember when
all those white people died to uh to try
to end slate
hey that's what i like throughout the
movie teamwork you know what i watch
with yeah i know i'm going on sorry i
was watching
what teamwork yeah teamwork makes the
dream work
that was what the unions was all about
there's no eye in slavery there's no
yeah i was watching the movie the bone
collector last night i was in oh yeah
were you yeah extra wait
i think you're thinking about montreal
no bone collector with with uh angelina
jolie
yeah yeah you were in it as an extra he
was alone on the train track at the very
beginning yeah so we're my parents yeah
we paid for our vacation nice oh yeah
well it's not a bad movie it's not bad
no no no but i was watching and it's
like it's denzel washington angelina
jolie and i was like oh yeah no one
cared about the race thing then no that
was like the it was a nice callback you
got el bundy in there yeah i don't know
what was in there and he's great in it i
love that o'neill yeah yeah i was just
thinking it's just so different it is
absolutely different like they'd be
forcing all the stuff together and it's
like this is a movie of a completely
mixed demographic but it was just who
was best for the role yeah so describe
to me what it would be now dave what
give me give me angelina jolie's
backstory this time around oh this time
around uh well she's a lesbian she's
been abused by your father there's no
doubt about that yeah uh
what about denzel well he's a paraplegic
in the movie so now it would be wrongly
heartbreaking because he can no longer
have sex with felt rabbits that's true
so now they wouldn't want somebody who's
non-pera right to actually play the role
so they'd have to get a real pera yes
yes
okay well what about the villain in this
movie i mean what's the backstory well i
think he'd still be the white guy
yeah you would not have to reshoot the
ending no no no no
it's totally normal but it would be
blamed for being a white guy that same
thing with the same thing with fallen
where denzel's a good guy i would still
be the white guy
is on my side yes yes it is and it's
creepy as hell very creepy oh it's a
white guy
yeah that's probably the creepiest part
i'm gonna show up and do my taxes
i'll get a great reason silverberg
so
the glory is hard to watch on a plane
when there's passengers around you and
you're like
sorry about that yeah
our bad
or roots yeah yeah it's nice they just
see that good place and you're like oh
boy okay stop playing spirit dave oh
they don't have tvs
no spirit doesn't i mean going around
there's people on board carrying them
yes
with the price tags yeah
what are you looking at it's a floor
model [ __ ] carry on we are gonna fit
under the seat gonna have a twerking
contest for the 32-inch
these surprises we got some headwinds
and we also have our own comp usa kiosk
you thought it didn't exist but actually
they moved to spirit so comp usa at the
front
kiosks
thank you for working spirit seed 13d
has won a cricket phone yes
and an obama phone [ __ ] i'm on boost
[Laughter]
you get points yes
uh
so the only this is something that
trevor noah now speaking of the media
this all this all this happens to be
taking place right after the former vice
president reached out to media saying
like wow could you give us better
coverage so trevor noah is now saying
that the only reason for the high fuel
prices but i just thought that don lemon
said
fuel prices are really low yeah the fuel
prices they're low fuel prices now
trevor noah is saying well actually
they're high but it's because an insert
whatever bs excuse here uh because
there's not enough to meet the post
pandemic demand here is uh here is
economist trevor now one of the reasons
gas prices are so high is because
america is making less gas than it did
before the pandemic because people may
be driving again but that doesn't mean
that it's easy for gas producers to just
instantly produce as much as they were
before
you got to grow a whole new dinosaur and
then smoosh it until the oil comes out
that takes time
and it makes sense that it's going to
take them time to adjust
i mean it's been hard for all of us
right every single one of us it's been
hard for us to get back to normal life
after the pandemic
shut up shut up i don't like your stupid
haircut and i could hurt you i'm so
tired when he this we're all in this
together no you are not six million a
year salary for sucking for no we are
not all in this together and many people
want out
i just i am so
i've had it up to here with turbo man so
when these people say we're all in it
together like it's been gone for all of
us doesn't no it hasn't and i
acknowledge it hasn't been as hard to me
you know what i was made for this i'm
bordering in howard hughes i'm a recluse
i'm a hermit i don't need to go out and
touch people like how are you dealing
with quarantine i said the what now
maybe you guys who's still out but i
haven't said we're all in this together
because we're not you also haven't made
terrible jokes it takes time to grow a
dinosaur and smoosh it yeah oh silly
noah he thinks dinosaurs are real
wouldn't there just be a surplus of gas
if no one was using it you would think
so no dave that's not yeah i'm sorry i
mean there's logic supply side economics
voodoo economic so uh here's the thing
yes it is true that demand has gone up
since pre-pandemic a little bit so you
can say that that's a portion of the
equation
but uh everything by the way not just
guess everything is more expensive uh
you have the consumer price index right
the inflation the cpi rose six point
eight percent year over year the most in
uh
40 40 years wow 40 years lowest couple
so earlier lowest i just want to show my
confusion lowest job participation 45
right and then the highest inflation in
40. what yeah i think it's 39 years to
be but only if you look at it like that
yes you know so uh
over the over the past year fuel's gone
up 59.1 percent this is like the
greatest hits right rounding error used
cars 26.4 percent that number's probably
higher now yes food fun oh yeah three
percent that's not really important you
don't need to eat to live meat and eggs
eleven point nine percent and shelter
shelters three and a half percent
increase which doesn't sound like a lot
hold on
but shelter usually costs a whole lot
more money so in raw dollars that's a
lot that's an absolute that's a lot of
money but at least blackrock will just
still be making away like bandits
and then we'll just declare everything a
human right right just raise the cost
just raise the cost on everything and
say well it's a human right look people
can't afford meat and eggs it's a human
right people can't afford internet it's
a human right people can't afford gas
it's a human right that's what you've
seen happen across europe and uh i don't
know if you know this prices have
actually gone up as well in these
countries so inflation begins more
inflation well i i myself enjoy the new
mcdonald's 99 value menu yes
absolutely by the way for anyone
watching the video of the uh the show
and if they were confused the trevor no
clip it said it was 9 10 2019 that was
actually from november 16 2021. oh
2019 yeah oh 20 now
wrong date date somebody's getting
whipped bad dates admonish
them back there admonish them back their
quarterback
there we go
and by the way a lot of people
understand like you say you make
everything a human right or you just you
know ubi or you just give people cash
handouts that's a big reason by the way
that everything is becoming more
expensive yeah if you have people for
example you know um and this is overlay
l1 there uh token owen
cash handouts it it it artificially
decreases uh worker uh a worker surplus
increases demand and so then they have
to pay more and people say why don't you
pay a living wage look it's no longer
about 15 an hour because you can get a
15 an hour job anywhere in this country
at this point so long as you have i mean
as long as you i mean if you can
are you allowed to do that if you can do
this like a fly you can get a 50 an hour
job if you have a pulse right now you
get 100 an hour job and there's there's
if a pedophile can work at cnn for four
years i'm pretty sure you can uh find
yourself a part-time at duncan you know
how you know this is not sustainable
joe biden is doing it by giving free
cash away and asking the congress to
give away more right trillions of
dollars in other plans donald trump did
it by making the economy actually work
right
that's a that's a totally different
thing mr kramer well they don't want
this economy to work no they want the
government to be able to give you more
so you can be dependent on them that's
how you ultimately just beat people into
submission is the more you convince them
it is it's like an abusive relationship
the more you convince them that they
cannot do anything without you the more
you convince them that they need you and
you do it for a long enough amount of
time and just like if you have an
abusive relationship an abusive spouse
who cuts out friends who oh i don't like
this person because i give you a
different opinion if you cut out
on facebook on twitter on youtube on
google of course on all of mainstream
media people who say actually this isn't
good you you can go out and do this
yourself you can live the american dream
eliminate those voices and tell them no
you can't no you can't you need us when
they say yes we can they mean yes we the
government can and if they convince you
of that then it becomes stockholm
syndrome that is absolutely what they're
trying this is actually more pimp logic
it is which is you get exactly what i
give you and we keep 100
yep i mean that's essentially what it is
it's just to create a bunch of
subservient low iq people former vice
president joe biden or his son got to
keep his pimping strong press it's true
though it's easy mama it isn't
easy
biden can't move like that anymore
what are you talking about you would
throw his hippie president spending g's
yes
um
also by the way there's all this free
money creating a massive labor shortage
10.4 million job openings in the u.s
compared to 6.8 million openings in
november 2019 now i know you may not
more openings is a bad thing right that
means fewer jobs are being filled last
month employers only added 210 000 jobs
oh no that's the fewest in half a year
they expected more than twice that wall
street jim cramer hey jim cramer what
happened to your squeaky mallet yeah so
many times they've missed all you had to
do
was take a knee and not do anything the
vaccine had come in you were about to
win joe biden
and then you showed up people got real
mad at ihop
they did just pointing that out why are
people mounted on oh yeah because they
put up a sign that said like we uh
because of you know biden basically our
food sucks because of biden well what
happened where am i going to go to not
eat pancakes i know it's not it's the
easiest place i've ever boycotted yeah i
was like oh i did it by eating there
once
but it took a sign for you to do it yeah
what's next bob evans yeah oh
the three that are left yeah hey there's
one right by notre dame you be careful
arthur treachers that perkins
lord just don't take my tim horton's i
don't know what to do
but i don't love tim bits i will
celebrate if you take away tim hartman
why timbits because those pricks up
north have to pay right so
uh this is another claim they're trying
to make here about oil gas prices again
you have to look at they always say look
at the holistic approach nuance is the
word the left uses in this case it's not
nuanced it's just the aggregate uh the
aggregation here facts all of these are
relevant because if you just look in the
vacuum and say gas prices are well
they're good they're the best in a month
as tom lemon said but you say gas prices
are bad that doesn't tell the whole
story you look at prices for everything
is bad and then employment is bad labor
force participation is bad but to go
back to the oil prices and as someone
who lived in quebec a lot of people
don't know this quebec is bordering on
just effectively an all-out socialist
province
i experience this quite a bit they want
to vilify opec so these policies have
led to
gas prices increasing
but of course you have trevor noah who i
don't know why he's discussing anything
in the united states his country is
absolutely awful how about you get your
own house in order and by that i mean
make one city any city livable
just in all of south africa so uh
they're saying that opec and russia are
restricting supply which is what's
driving oil prices higher now if america
isn't making enough oil to keep up with
demand then why doesn't it just buy more
from the rest of the world well it could
but it turns out that right there's a
big switch
well they just don't feel like sharing
prices really
driving demand on the horizon it's
really more about the supply oil
producing nations are actually
constricting the supply a little bit
because they're trying to recoup their
pandemic losses there's a cartel that
controls the price of oil
internationally and that cartel is
called opec opec
it looks like a terrorist jake
gyllenhaal aren't increasing the amount
of
terrorist experts global economy so as
demand rebounds in the u.s
americans are paying about 16
more to fill up their tanks than a year
ago president biden recently appealed to
opec and russia to boost production but
received a flat no wow they received a
flat no
okay first of all balls
what is that i was saying he has no
balls that's why yeah well that's true
i was gonna say something else i'm gonna
be careful
uh
we don't let me be really clear
russia if the united states was simply
continuing to do what it did under
donald trump right okay russia opec
could not be less relevant it's a
non-issue doesn't matter why trevor noah
said himself 2018 the united states
became the world's largest uh producer
of oil september 2019
the united states became a net exporter
of petroleum for the first time on
record wow and then stopped
so eve here's the thing even if you
believe that everyone should be driving
their priuses which by the way is a
shitty car it's like riding a shopping
cart with batteries and i don't know
when everyone and anyone who cannot
drive had a meeting behind our backs and
decided you're going to drive in a prius
but we give you at least two lanes of
swath because of how awful you are so i
don't care if you drive your priest i
don't care if you use one square
right like cheryl crow where after after
you've wiped your ass you look like a
mechanic who's been working in the shop
for 20 20 hours a day i don't care if
you do all of those things
we're still using oil at this point in
time in history you think we're better
off getting it
from across
the globe where by the way they have to
come over on tanks and the bp oil spill
is nothing compared to the split spells
that happen every single year on these
barges just to be clear you just don't
know about them because they often
happen in the middle of the ocean not to
mention a lot of these countries don't
have the same epa standards that we have
here but mainly the most important thing
i don't give a rat's ass if every
seagull on the shore bathes itself in
crisco for all i care i
want cheap gas energy and i want it to
be made here in the united states one of
the best reasons is because we're
getting a lot of it right now from let's
see really nice world players like
russia who every time we give them more
money seems to take over another country
it's kind of weird how that works and
also your favorite place for women's
rights saudi arabia those are places
that i thought you hated yeah they can
power their cars women just can't drive
them no no that's true but they can do
the work to make sure that they can get
hit with them yes
well yeah i mean that's just a safety
thing depending on the day yeah
they get some things right so biden's
first day first day
killed the keystone xl pipeline just to
be clear right uh that would have
brought 800 000 barrels of oil per day
also suspended more drilling leases in
alaska okay so keep in mind this is in
the context the united states was the
net
a net exporter of oil in 2019 for the
first time ever that's better for
everyone in the world by the way yeah
uh biden lifted
however contrasting with what he did
with our own pipelines lifted sanctions
on russia's nordstream 2 pipeline which
by the way makes them a key player and
of course emboldens them as it relates
to ukraine and that whole sort of
geopolitical i don't know what you'd
call it brew ha ha hoot nanny whatever
you want to say he wants to be friendly
you know in other words look how do what
does it take for you to realize that
this is political expediency yeah you
can't say okay we want us to we want to
uh we want to reduce our dependency on
any sort of fossil fuels and uh you know
uh petroleum so we're going to ban all
these pipelines in the united states
we're going to stop this we're going to
stop fracking which is cleaner which is
safer but we're going to open it up for
russia abroad i would have more respect
for him if he tried to play but the
issue is he's a bully what i mean by
that it's very easy when you can with a
pen stop a lease here in the united
states you can stop a pipeline here in
the united states a [ __ ] can do that
but if you have to stare down putin you
have to put your foot down you can't so
what you do is you bully american
workers you bully american companies who
are trying to create
produce export oil because it's easy
you're picking a fight you know you can
win because you have the power of the
pen and the government you don't have
that same power over putin it would
require more of a fight it would require
that you actually have some balls bite
down on the mouth guard and swing for
something that matters it is because
this administration they are cowardly in
the face of international intimidation
and they are bullies when it comes to
the american middle class does that make
sense absolutely and we're going to see
that by the way if you live in uh and in
the country that's about to be taken
over by right just change your flags
ukraine just go ahead and change them
now yeah
it's an easier path yep so because
you're not gonna be a trainer don't
depend on us because right now something
nice we're just gonna have
teleconferences and say that there's
going to be severe yeah i mean we'll
send you to bed without dinner i just
hope there's one ukrainian he's like
okay okay
calm your jets i'm going to change
ukraine okay ukraine flag come down and
we put up russian oh it's putin with
penis on face i'll do that
okay i go to gulag
i really hope they do stuff like that
please
so
uh let me just give you a couple of
quick new epa methane regulations are
going to cost small oil producers 600
million dollars a year biden's budget
plan will increase taxes on the industry
by over 120 billion over the next 10
years november propane prices are up 34
hope forever all americans out there if
you need to heat your house i don't know
do you do you have a gas stove and uh in
rural minnesota it's up 60 percent
remember when they said net neutrality
this is the whole reasons to help people
in rural areas without broadband yeah i
don't know more important than being
able to watch pornography you would
think would be heating your home in
rural minnesota no you'll just freeze to
death but you'll have good internet
enough porn you'll be nice and hot
stop it rosy cheek like that cnn yes
indeed
john kerry he's also pushing banks to
stop financing fossil fuel companies
oh good yeah
help because they want to push here's
the thing they want to push companies to
building more electric cars okay okay
let's say okay okay right now well we
need it we need it we can't have fossil
fuels any of these because we need to
build electric cars okay so we don't
have them yet that's correct
how are you going to build them
already punished the energy that would
be required to make them why do you
think elon musk effectively
the george washington of the electric
vehicle left california where these
policies exist to go to texas
how are you going to build the electric
cars i think i'm going to be an electric
car mechanic because all i have to do is
go yep it's your battery yep
that's the problem and then order a new
one for them yeah gonna be three to six
months just pull it out from an rc car
hold on i got a bunch of these yeah a
remote but you'll only be able to turn
left
are you sure it's not something else
yeah
there is nothing sure right it could be
the fire that was on your battery ah
yeah well
it seems like tomato tomato and by the
way let's say you find a way to build
the electric cars with wind turbines and
sun
and clouds how are you going to charge
the electric cars oh uh oh we're just
we're not there yet and all of the
innovations that have actually taken
place as it relates to cleaner energy
have been in the private sector not at
the end of the barrel of a government
gun okay solyndra you know uh and here's
another thing uh in case you're doubting
what i'm saying i'll reference the video
credit.com biden's first comp was it
comp troller is the role
yeah comptroller nominee saul i want to
get this right saul
omarova she's going to be overseeing the
banks well this is what she said
for certain uh troubled industries and
firms that are in transitioning and here
what i'm thinking about is primarily
coal industry and oil and gas industry a
lot of the smaller players in that
industry are
uh going to probably uh go bankrupt in
in in short order at least we want them
to go bankrupt if we want to tackle
climate change right now let me repeat
that what
just so you guys are she said we want
them to go bankrupt
if we want to tackle climate change
hey okay while we're bankrupting people
you first [ __ ] how about that yes
file chapter 11 and i'll start using one
square
you know if we just kill all the people
from killing the economy yes climate
change won't kill them that's true oh i
mean that's
that's like a charm with venezuela yeah
they're they they can't find any toilet
paper squares and they're dying well
there's just too many people for the
toilet paper so you got to get rid of
the people not increase the toilet paper
right exactly yeah i mean that just
makes perfect sense yeah it's about
supply side economics what are you going
to supply more toilet paper no you
killed more people oh we can't do that i
can't spare a square you can not spare a
square or a human at this point
apparently what i mean who am i uh uh a
rockefeller
come on please
spare a square who's she talking about
are the small players in the oil
industry there are plenty of people are
there yeah and again this is a perfect
example of the only players left are the
mega billion that's what i assumed was
only there yeah well and by the way
there are quite a few companies that
have to uh give some nice political
contributions yes they make sure that
they uh stay well of course yeah that's
you know because everything's awful and
corrupting here's uh by the way uh is
this is this another noah clip saying
yes there's there's nothing there's
nothing biden can do i feel like this is
almost redundant about gas prices so the
big question is what can be done to
lower gas prices
well the bad news for president biden is
not much wrong the biden administration
is scrambling for solutions to one of
his biggest biggest political
liabilities
soaring gas prices like presidents who
came before him joe biden has few
options when it comes to combating high
fuel prices nearly
senate democrats are calling on biden to
consider all the tools available at your
disposal even the extreme step of
banning american oil exports which
goldman sachs warned would be
counterproductive and could actually
raise prices of course the president
also considering tapping the strategic
petroleum reserve industry experts have
warned that would do little to alleviate
the problem if you ask the energy
industry they would say well the white
house could cut environmental regulation
and maybe that would help and it could
maybe for next winter but that would
take some time president biden does not
have a magic wand to dramatically lower
gas prices and if he did judging upon
his sinking poll numbers he would use
that magic wand he'd probably wave it to
make a six-year-old appear to sniff so
let's just be what could he do okay he
could stop printing cash to reduce the
crazy massive inflation right off the
bat while we're talking about gas price
of the average american uh roll back
industry crippling regulations okay he
could allow us to uh tap into untapped
reserves and he could at the very least
allow us to have access to our own
energy reserves and pipelines those
things would help and
the reason i say
maybe we could get to the point of being
a net exporter of oil because for the
first time in our recorded history we
did that under president donald trump
and we had record low gas prices when
you look at them for history uh their
point in history
absolutely he was doing a fantastic job
just get out of the way joe biden get
out of the way that's what you can by
the way if he has no magic wand that he
can do anything about gas prices you
cannot don lemon go out and say the
president has done a great job of
bringing down gas prices even though
you're lying about how far they've come
well they can't even come together on
the lie that's the thing one guy's like
oh you know what there's nothing you can
do about these high gas prices and don
lemon's like oh shoot i already wrote my
script uh gas prices aren't high sorry
it's too late
and the red line is a great job with
that yeah strategic oil reserve yeah by
the way they showed some guy filling up
like a 98 like gmc jimmy yeah like every
car they i like go ask those people how
they feel about the gas price it was oj
filling up his broncos
it seems like they're killing it at life
and probably just want to tell you how
happy they are well their solutions
right well what don't drive a
gas-guzzling car oh do you have a family
people who live in rural america or even
suburban america and some of them work
blue collar jobs or have a large amount
of people to transport minivans
full-size suvs pickup trucks we don't
all live in a giant cesspool of filth
and sadness that is san francisco and
drive smart cars
just to be clear but also a lot of cars
that you don't even have a car yeah like
you just get around by the the bus or
the train right you don't even have a
car
yeah or if you buy a car that's used
because it's what you can afford like
let's say to go to your job most of them
are going to be
gas-guzzling cars because they're older
cars that you can afford guess what
that's still it's still better for the
environment to buy an old gas guzzling
car than it is to buy a new one people
don't like to talk about that
still better to buy an old gasoline
guzzling car than it is to buy a new
tesla
or a new prius people don't understand
it's already there it doesn't need to be
made
recycle
well it's like three thousand dollars
versus sixty thousand dollars yes that's
a huge difference in what people can
afford well that's just for you because
it's a rapist fan well i'm not all
first of all the paint job itself was
three grand yeah well you'd have to
paint over the windows well that's part
of it yeah he did and i'm on a bear skin
rock he painted them he wrapped the
windows in wood paneling i did which was
weird and it is very sound proof i
assure you
you have a party with cnn producers
it's a cnn van you get in you're like
why is this just what this is
just luscious foam staples everywhere ah
this is weird it's a rotating fur bed is
this for wrapping yeah this is odd it
looks like a studio now here's one thing
too i will leave you with this i was
raised i've seen this happen a lot of
people say why are we raising can you
know raising canada but this patriotic
american because i was raised in
effectively what is socialism i
experienced socialized healthcare the
first video i ever did on location uh
the first one of the first louder with
crowder installments was you know back
in 2009 uh and i went down and just had
a hidden camera in canadian healthcare
socialized healthcare system i went to
the hospitals
where i was treated as a kid
and i just knew that it wasn't what
americans thought the same thing as it
relates to energy prices we came to the
united states when i moved to the united
states i could not believe the low cost
of drug prices generics i couldn't
believe the low cost of actually seeing
a doctor here if you went to go see a
doctor with cash i could not believe the
prices on most consumables at the
grocery store it was unbelievable to me
and what shocked me most was the price
at the pump at that point it actually
was i think maybe twice the amount in
quebec just to be clear so right now it
actually looks like in quebec it's four
dollars and 92 cents
uh a gallon and keep in mind that would
typically be significantly higher in a
place like montreal and that's including
all of rural quebec where it'll be much
lower um
and it's very easy to vilify the oil
companies
and that's what everyone did they were
bitching going gas prices are so high
and the government would say hey man
don't look at me it's the company
petroleum but then finally the oil
company said really you think that it's
because of us that the gas prices are so
high they put a pie chart up on the
pumps that showed you how much was paid
in taxes how much was going to crude
costs versus actual profits they're like
we're not the bad guys 32
in taxes if you were to cut that to half
yikes wow half
that would make a huge difference for
quebecers i was about to say americans
uh
at the pump so this was i remember
actually like dad what's that what's
that he's like well uh
our politicians are [ __ ] son yeah
and when you go here to esso that was
like our exxon he was like when you go
here to esso or petro canada they want
you to blame this guy here pumping the
gas but really it's them so uh it's a
pie chart that says sorry not sorry yes
great precisely
so when you storm the provincial capital
it's not a thing in canada no no no
there's nothing uh i mean we still have
the queen on our money that's true
there's no storming in canada there's
bowing
chunies and loonies toonies and loonies
so it's really easy look and this is
something i think a lot of people if
you're new conservative to be led by the
nose and go oh evil oil companies and to
be fair they do provide a lot of
kickbacks to uh to government and there
are a lot of financial incentives for
the big oil companies not everyone in
energy i just want
i just want a fair playing field at this
point and i want americans to be able to
do
as good of a job as they possibly can
not only at work but as a father as a
mother as a as a husband it's hard to do
when everything is increasingly
expensive and your rights just keep
getting getting whittled and whittled
and whittled and whittled and whittled
away if you are watching right now smash
the like button here right before uh we
leave and leave your comment below if
you've experienced this inflation helps
a lot for the algorithm you can watch on
rumble we're going to play i believe uh
stephen no sports the heisman that's
right right
playing that on mud club that's true i
think so
stephen because they just gave that they
did yes was it a black guy it was uh
you'll sort it hey i've got it was a
black guy all right so we're gonna play
steven no sports on mug club youtube
piss off